this is great larry david screamed at
alan dershowitz at a grocery store
because he's mad that he's friends with
donald trump
or that he's in the trump team
i saw you with your arm around mike
pompeo it's disgusting dershowitz goes
he's my former student at harvard law i
greet all of my former students that way
i can't greet my former students david
it's disgusting your whole enclave it's
disgusting you're disgusting
then larry walks away allen takes off
his t-shirt to reveal another t-shirt
that says it's the constitution stupid
and then dershowitz drove off in an old
dirty volvo i love by the way that it
wasn't that he's been accused multiple
times of rape
by underage people
it's that he's like a republican
that's really if you want to talk about
hollywood that's the perfect
encapsulation of hollywood
you know
it'd be like if jeffrey epstein was
found out that he was alive and larry
david bumped into him in martha's
vineyard he'd be like i can't believe
you were such good friends with trump i
never knew that
by the way dershowitz uh has been
accused by this uh virginia giuffray
jeffrey yeah virginia guthrie of
molesting her right multiple times yeah
uh seven times seven times between the
ages of 16 and 19. that's too much
using some of the same language that he
had employed to describe epstein's
victims a decade earlier this is what
dershowitz called this woman this is how
you know she's telling the truth he
called her a serial liar a prostitute
and a bad mother
i mean
that sounds a bit personal for someone
you didn't rape
dersh
can you believe that
like if somebody accused you of rape
wouldn't your first question be like
what who how huh
but he's like she's a liar prostitute
and a bad mother it's like well it
sounds like you're protesting a little
bit too much
in fact i think that you know this woman
quite well and you may have done the
wrong thing to her
then he said who could not be believed
quote against somebody with an unscathed
reputation like me does he have an
unscathed reputation i don't know about
that
he insisted that guffrey had quote made
the whole thing up out of whole cloth in
search of quote a big payday
when a tv reporter in miami questioned
his characterization of guthrie a sex
abuse victim as quote a prostitute der
schwitz replied she made her own
decisions in life
he's basically admitting he [ __ ] her
but he's saying she's a prostitute who
cares she made her own decisions even
though she was underage
yeah
so it was just very interesting larry
david kind of like bumped into him in
martha's vineyard and was like hey
i cannot believe that you're a
republican
forget the friendship with jeffrey
epstein forget the multiple accusations
of of child rape
when two people when he but when when a
hollywood person and i love larry's
brilliant comedian but it's just funny
it's like
you know you are in a little bit of a
bubble unless there's more to this which
we didn't hear where he's and maybe
that's part of why he's grossed out by
dirsh but like you know you're in a
little bit of a bubble when somebody
walk you bump into
uh an accused child rapist on martha's
vineyard and your biggest problem with
them is that they're friends with the
trump team
that seems odd
larry's a knee jerk radical dershowitz
saw page six he takes his politics from
hollywood he doesn't read a lot he
doesn't think a lot
it's typical of what happens now on the
vineyard
says dersh
people who won't talk to each other if
they don't agree on their politics
well what about the child rape
i love this he goes
it's the price of principal
this guy
is a uh he's been involved in some very
uh very nefarious dealings
and he's probably done some horrible
things
and uh
what's funny now is that he relishes
this every time somebody yells at him
about being in the trump circle it's
it's it's a
it helps him because what they're not
yelling at him about is uh the
incredible accusations of child rape
that he's also
had a
large part of so like every interview he
does he's like i'm just they get mad at
me because i believe in the constitution
it's like that's not
alan
you know that's not it i just watched by
the way the people vs o.j simpson again
because it's on netflix it's great and
he's in that
not him but an actor
um
this is funny that was a great go back
to that uh photo
it's uh the noted lawyer's long
controversial quran it's jeffrey epstein
oj simpson
mike tyson
is that limbaugh i believe so yeah might
be lambot's trump
i don't know this is a good article
alan dershowitz article's devil's
advocate
i mean he's an amazing lawyer right i
mean we can't take that away from you
yeah sure he's a great lawyer
he'll be representing the taliban
soon
the taliban will have alan dershowitz
and he'll go people are mad cause i
represented the taliban
that's why they're angry he's gonna keep
doing controversial things to take the
heat off the whole epstein thing
he if he was smart right now he'd be in
afghanistan
defending the taliban so that people
you know
uh forget that he's been accused